The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, I guess it's
time to get started.
Next lecture, I'm going to try
to summarize what we've done
so that I want to try to finish
what we're going to
finish for the term today.
And that means we have a lot
of topics that all get
slightly squeezed in together,
including the martingale
convergence theorem and the
strengthening of the strong
law of large numbers and the
Kolmogorov's submartingale
inequalities and stopped
martingales.
So all of these are fairly
major topics.
One thing that it means is that
we certainly aren't going
to do much with the martingale
convergence theorem.
It's a major theorem
and advanced work.
What we're trying to do
here is just give you
some flavor of it.
The other things, as we move up
the chain there, we want to
know more and more about it.
And the things on top certainly
explain what's going
on in the things below.
OK, let's review what
a martingale is.
A sequence of random variables
is a martingale if it
satisfies this funny
looking condition.
When I write it this way, it's
not completely obvious what
it's saying.
But I think we know now the
expected value of one thing,
of one random variable, given a
set of random variables, is
really a random variable
in its own right.
And that's a random variable,
which is a function of those
conditioning random variables.
So expected value of Zn,
given Zn minus 1 to Z1.
It's a random variable.
It maps each sample point to the
conditional expectation of
Zn, conditional in
Z1 to Zn minus 1.
For martingale, this expectation
has to be this
random variable, Z
sub n minus one.
It has to be the most recent
random variable you've seen.
And then last time, we proved
this lemma, a pretty major
lemma, which says, for a
martingale, expected value of
Zn is equal to of Zn, given not
all of the past, but just
a certain number of elements of
the past Zn conditional and
Zi, back to Z1.
That's equal to Zi.
Expected value of Zn is equal
to the expected value of Zi.
We didn't talk about
this one last time.
But this is obvious
in terms of this.
If you take the expected value
of this over all of the
conditioning random variables,
then what you get is just the
expected value of Z sub i.
So that's what this says.
OK, question now.
Why is it that if you condition
on more random
variables than just Zn in the
paths, if you condition on
things into the future,
including Z sub n its self,
why is the expected value
of Zn given Zm down
to Zn down to Z1?
Why is that equal to Zn and
not equal to Zn minus 1?
If you understand this, you
understand what conditional
expectations are.
If you don't understand it,
you've got to spend some time
really thinking about what
conditional expectations are.
OK, how many people can see why
this, in fact, has to be
Zn and not something else?
AUDIENCE: We know Zn already.
PROFESSOR: What?
AUDIENCE: Isn't it-- don't
you know Zn already?
PROFESSOR: That's right.
Since you know the n already,
then you know it.
That's exactly what it says.
And we'll talk more about this
later because we actually use
this a bunch of times
when we're going on.
But what it says is that for
any given value of each of
these random variables, in other
words, for a given value
of Z sub n, the expected
value of Z sub n--
I mean, if I just wrote it, it's
what's the expected value
of Z sub n, given Z sub n?
What's the expected
value of Z sub n--
I'll make it even easier.
And you can see it
more clearly.
What's the expected value of Z
sub n, given that Z sub n is
equal to a particular
value z sub n.
OK, now I hope you can see
why it is that this is
equal to Z sub n.
That's the only thing
that the random
variable Z sub n can be.
For this sample point and the
conditioning, we're assuming
the sample value for which Z sub
n is equal to little z sub
n, and therefore that's
what this random
variable has to be.
That's what you said
in one sentence.
And I'm saying it in
five sentences.
It's hard enough that you want
to say it in five sentences
because this is not
an obvious thing.
It's not an obvious thing until
you really have a sense
of what these conditional
expectations mean.
And that's part of our function
for the last couple
of weeks, to sort out what
those things mean because
that's part of understanding
what martingales are doing.
OK, when we go one step further
on this, we've said
that the expected value of Z sub
n, given Z sub i back to Z
sub n is Z sub i, so the
expected value of Z sub n,
only given Z sub 1, is
equal to Z sub 1.
That's what this says, an
expected value of Z sub n then
is equal to the expected
value of Z sub 1.
It says these marginal
expectations are all the same.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Why don't you just
say that the expectation of
the Zs are constant.
I mean, it seems like this is
kind of a roundabout way of
saying that.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, in a sense.
But if you want to--
almost all the examples you
can think of, it's hard to
figure out what these Z sub n's
are because the Z sub n's
are given in terms of all of the
previous random variables.
If you want to sort out what a
martingale is, and you can't
even understand what Z sub 1
is, then you're in trouble.
I mean, it makes the theorem
more abstract to say the
expected value of Z sub n is
a constant random variable
rather than saying which
random variable it is.
And it's obvious what random
variable it is.
I mean, Z1 is one
example of it.
So you're right.
You could say that way.
OK, so we talked about a number
of simple examples of
martingales last time.
All of these examples assume
that the expected value of the
magnitude of Z sub n is less
than infinity for all n.
Remember, this does not mean
that the expected value of Z
sub n is bounded over all n.
I mean, you can have expected
value of Z to the n
can be 2 to the n.
It can be shooting off to
infinity very, very fast.
But it still is finite
for every value of n.
That's what this
assumption is.
Later on, when we talk about
the martingale convergence
theorem, we'll assume that
these expectations are
bounded, which is a much, much
stronger constraint.
OK, we talked about these
examples last time.
All of them are pretty important
because any time
you're trying to do a problem
with martingales, trying to
prove something for martingales,
what I like to do
first is to look at all the
simple examples I know and try
to get some insight from them
as to whether the result is
true or whether it's not true.
And if you can't see from the
examples what's going on, then
you're sort of stuck for the
most part, unless you're lucky
enough to construct the kind
of proof you would
find in a math book.
Now math book theorem
proofs are beautiful
because they're the--
I mean, mathematicians work to
get the shortest possible
proof they can, which has
no holes in it at all.
And that makes it
very elegant.
But when you're trying to
understand it, what is often
done is somebody starts out
understanding a theorem, and
they write a proof which
runs for three pages.
And then they think about
it for two weeks.
They cut it down to one page.
They think about it for
another two weeks.
They cut it down
to half a page.
And then they publish it.
And all they do is publish
the half page.
Everybody is stuck.
Nobody knows where
this came from.
So what I'm trying to do here
is, at least in some cases, to
give you a little more than the
half page to give you some
idea of where these things come
from, the extent I can.
OK so the zero mean
random walk--
if Z sub n is equal to some of
Xi, where Xi are IID and zero
mean , then this zero mean
random walk is, in fact, a
martingale, just satisfies
the conditions.
This one is probably the most
important of all of the simple
examples because it says if
Z sub n is a sum of random
variables--
don't know what the random
variables so are-- the
condition on the random
variables is the expected
value of X sub i, given all
the previous ones is 0.
This is a general example
because every martingale in
the world you can look at the
increments of that martingale,
namely you can define X sub
n to be Z sub n minus
Z sub n minus 1.
And as soon as you do that,
X sub n satisfies
this condition here.
And what you've got for sure is
a martingale, so that this
condition here, that the X sub
is are satisfying, is really
the same as a martingale
condition.
It's just that when people are
talking about martingales,
they're talking about the sums
of random variables.
Here we're just talking about
the random variables
themselves.
It's like when we talk about sum
of IID random variables,
we prove the laws of large
numbers and everything.
What we're really talking
about there
is IID random variables.
What we're really talking about
here is these random
variables, which has the
property that no matter what's
happened in the past, the
expected value of this new
random variable is equal to 0.
People call these fair games.
And they call martingales
examples of fair games.
And martingale, the expected
value of Z sub n, you can
think of it as you're
expecting that
worth of time n.
And with these underlying random
variables, the X sub i,
the X sub i is, in a sense,
your profit at time n.
And what this says is your
profit at time n is
independent of everything in the
past, independent of every
sample value of everything
in the past.
And this is why people
call it fair game.
It's really a very strong
definition of a fair game.
I mean, it's saying
an awful lot.
I mean, everybody says
life is not fair.
Surely by this definition, life
is not even close to fair
because when you look
at all your past--
I mean, you try to learn
from your past.
This is saying in these kinds
of gambling games, you can't
learn from the past.
You can't do anything with it
so long as you're interested
only in the expectation.
The expectation of X sub i is
equal to 0, no matter what all
the earlier random
variables are.
This, I think, gives you a sense
of what a martingale is,
probably better than the
original definition.
OK, another one we talked
about last time,
this is very specific.
Suppose that X sub i is equal
to the product of two random
variables, U sub i
times Y sub i.
The U sub i here are IID
equiprobable, plus or minus 1.
And the Y sub is are independent
of the U sub is.
They can be anything at all.
And when you take these Y sub
is, which are anything at all,
but these quantities here, which
are IID 1 and minus 1,
when you look at this product
here, any positive number this
can be is equiprobable with the
corresponding negative number.
And that means when you take
the expectation of X sub i,
given any old thing in the past,
this U sub i is enough
to make the expectation
equal to 0.
So this is a fairly strong kind
of example also, which
gives you a sense of what
these things are.
Product form martingales--
you use product form martingales
primarily to find
counter examples of theorems.
If you stated a theorem
and it isn't true--
almost all the examples I know
of of reasonable martingale
theorems which are not true,
you look at a product
martingale, and very often
you look at this product
martingale down here, and you
find out either that the
theorem is not true, which lets
you stop looking at it.
Or it says, well, it still
isn't clear from that.
OK, so the product form
martingale, there's a sequence
of IID unit-mean random
variables.
And Zn, which is the product,
is then a martingale, if you
assume this condition
up here, of course.
And this condition here, the
probability that the n-th
order product, namely the
product of n of these sample
values, if you get one
0, the product is 0.
So you're done.
So the only question is,
do you get all 1s?
Or do you get something
other than all 1s?
If you get all 1s, then the
product of these random
variables is 2 to the n.
You get 2 to the n with
probability 2 to the minus n.
And you get zero with all the
rest of the probability.
The limit as n goes to infinity
if Z sub n is equal
to zero with probability
1, namely eventually
you go down to 0.
And you stay there
forever after.
And with this very small
probability, you get to some
humongous number.
And you keep going up until
eventually you lose, and you
go down to 0.
So the limit for the expected
value of Z sub n--
for every n the expected value
of Z sub n is equal to 1.
That's what makes this
example interesting.
The limit of the expected
value of the Z sub
ns is equal to 1.
But the Z sub ns themselves go
to 0 with probability 1.
And the reason for that is that
you had this enormous
growth here with very
small probability.
But it's enough to keep the
expectation equal to 1.
OK, then we started to talk
about sub and super
martingales.
And I told you if you can't
remember what the definition
of a submartingale is in terms
of is it less than or equal or
greater than or equal, just
remember that it's not
what it should be.
It's the opposite of
So the expected value of Z sub
n given the past is greater
than or equal to Z
sub n minus 1.
That means it's a
submartingale.
In other words, submartingales
grow in time.
Supermartingales
shrink in time.
And that's strange.
But that's the way it is.
If this quantity is a
submartingale, then minus Zn
is a supermartingale
and vice versa.
So I'm going to only talk about
submartingales from now
on because supermartingales just
do everything the same,
but just look at minus signs
instead of plus signs.
So why bother yourself
with one thing
extra to think about?
So for submartingales, the
expected value of Z sub n
given the past, given part of
the past from i down to 1, is
greater than or equal
to Z sub i.
That's essentially the same as
that theorem we've stated
before, which said that for
martingales, the expected
values of Zn given Zi down to
Z1 was equal to Z sub i.
You remember we proved that in
detail last time because that
was a crucially important
theorem.
You take that proof and you
put this inequality in it
instead of a quality, and it
immediately gives you this.
You just follow that proof
step by step, putting an
equality in in place
of a quality.
And same thing here, the
expected value of Z sub n is
greater than or equal to the
expected value of Z sub i.
That's true for all i.
So the expected value of Zn is
also greater than or equal to
the expected value Z1.
In other words, the expected
values of these random
variables, in fact,
always grow.
Or if they don't grow, they
at least stay the same.
They can't shrink.
OK, we started to talk about
convex functions last time.
I want to remind you
what they are.
A function which carries the
real numbers into the real
numbers is convex, if each
tangent of the curve lies on
or below the curve.
Here's a picture of it.
Here's a function h of x, a
one-dimensional function.
So you can draw x on the line.
And h of x is something which
goes up and down.
And here's another example.
H of x is equal to the
magnitude of x.
You're usually used to thinking
of convex functions
in terms of functions that
have a positive second
derivative.
Taking the geometric view, you
get something considerably
more general because it includes
all of these cases,
as well as all of these cases.
And this idea of tangents lying
on or below the line
gives you the linkage here.
You have something which comes
down, goes to 0, and
then goes up again.
Think of drawing tangents
to this curve.
Tangents have to have a slope
starting here and
going around to here.
And all of those tangents
hit at that point there.
So this is a very pathological
thing.
But all the tangents indeed
do lie below the curve.
So you've satisfied
the condition.
The lemma is Jensen's
inequality.
It says, if h is convex and Z
is a random variable with
finite expectation, then h of
the expected value of Z is
less than or equal to the
expected value of h of Z. This
seems sort of obvious,
perhaps.
It's one of those things which
either seems obvious or it
doesn't seem obvious.
And if it doesn't seem obvious,
it doesn't become
obvious terribly easily.
But what I want to do here is
to convince you of why it's
true by looking at a little
triangle here.
I can think of the random
variable Z as having three
possible values--
one over here where we get
this point comes into the
curve, one here, and one here.
Now if I take those three
possible values of x and I
think of assigning all
possible probability
assignments to those three
possible values, what happens?
If I assign all the probability
over here, I get
that point.
If I assign all the probability
here, I get that point.
And for everything else, it
lies inside that triangle.
And you can convince yourselves
of that pretty easily.
So for all of those probability
measures where the
expected value lies on this
line, what you get is
something between this and this
as the expected value of
h of Z. So you get something
above the line for the
expected value for h.
Of expected values of Z, you
just get this point right
there, which is clearly smaller
than anything you can
generate out of that triangle
or quadrilateral or any kind
of straight line figure that you
draw, which is the set of
expected values you can get from
probabilities using the
points on that--
well, it's what I said it was.
OK, Jensen's inequality leads
to the following theorem.
And I'm not going to prove
it here in class.
It's one of those theorems
which is sort of
obvious and not quite.
So if you want to see the proof,
you can look at it.
Or if you want to, you
can just believe it.
If Z sub n is a martingale or
it's a submartingale and if h
is convex, then the expected
value of the magnitude of h of
Zn is less than infinity
for all n.
Then h of Zn is a
submartingale.
In other words, when you have
that convex function, you go
from something which is a
martingale, which will be what
you would get on the line to
something which is bigger than
that, so that what you get is
the fact that expected value
of h of Z is, in fact, growing
with time, faster than the
martingale itself is growing.
OK, so one example of this is
if z of n is a martingale,
then the absolute value of Z
sub n is a submartingale.
Submartingales are
martingales.
Martingales are submartingales
also.
So I don't have to keep saying
that if it's a martingale or a
submartingale.
I can just say if it's
a submartingale.
This theorem is usually stated
as, if Z of n is a martingale,
then h of Zn is a submartingale,
which is true.
But just as obviously, if Zn is
a submartingale, which is
more general, h of Zn is
also a submartingale.
So you don't get out of the
realm of submartingales by
taking convex functions.
And you also get that Z squared
is a martingale.
And E to the rZn is a martingale
because all of
those are convex functions.
So when you want to look at any
of those, you just go from
talking about a martingale to
talking about a submartingale.
And life is easy again.
OK, major topic-- stopped
martingales.
We've talked about stopping
rules before.
And a stopping rule, we were
interested in stopping rules
when we were mostly talking
about renewal processes.
But stopping rules can be
applied to any sequence of
random variables at all.
What a stopping rule is, you
remember, is you have a
sequence of random variables,
any kind of random variable.
And a stopping rule is a rule
where the time that you stop
is determined by the things that
you've seen up until the
time that you stop.
You can't peak at
future values.
You have to look at these sample
values one by one as
they arrive.
And a stopping rule is something
which, when you get
to the point you want to stop,
you know that you want to stop
there from the sample values
you've already observed.
So when you're playing poker
with somebody, which I think
we talked about before, and you
make a bet and you lose,
you cannot withdraw your bet.
You cannot say, I stopped!
I stopped before!
The time that you stop depends
on what you've already seen up
until the time that you stop.
We talked about possibly
defective
random variables before.
I realized I never defined
a possibly
defective random variable.
In fact, somebody asked me
afterwards if it could be just
any old thing at all.
And I said, no.
And here's what it is.
It's a mapping from the sample
space to a set of real values,
to the extended real values.
And it has the property that
for a defective random
variable, the mapping can
give you plus infinity.
Or it can give you
minus infinity.
And it can give you either one
of those with positive
probability rather than
just 0 probability.
So it applies to these cases
where you have a threshold, a
single threshold, for
a random walk.
And you might cross the
threshold, or you might never
cross the threshold.
So it applies to conditions
where sometimes you stop and
sometimes you just keep
on going forever.
So it's nice for that
kind of situation.
The other provisos a random
variable back when we defined
random variables still hold
for a possibly defective
random variable.
So you have a distribution
function.
It's just the distribution
function doesn't necessarily
go to 1, and it doesn't
necessarily start at 0.
It could be somewhere
in between.
OK, so a stop process for a
possibly defective stopping
time satisfies Z sub n star,
which is Z sub n star is the
stopping time.
Let me start on that.
We have now defined
stopping rules.
We now want to define
a stop process.
A stop process is a process
which runs along until you
decide you're going to stop.
But before when we stopped, the
game was over and nothing
else happened.
Here, the idea is to game
continues forever.
But you stop playing, OK?
So the sequence of random
variables continues forever.
But the random variable of
interest to you is this
quantity Z sub n star, which at
the point you stopped, then
all subsequent Z sub n's
are just equal to
that stopped value.
So you're talking about some
kind of gambling game now,
perhaps, where you
play for a while.
And you're playing some
game where the
game continues forever.
And you make your bets
according to
some strange algorithm.
And when you've made $10,
you say, that's
all I want to make.
I'm happy with that.
And I'm not going to become the
kind of gambler who can
never stop.
So I'm going to stop
at that point.
So your capital remains $10
forever after, although the
game keeps on going.
And if you start out with a
capital of $10 and you lose it
all and you can't borrow
anything, then you stop also
when your capital becomes
minus $10.
So you can see that this is
a useful thing when you're
talking about threshold
crossings because when you
have a random walk and you have
a threshold crossing, you
can stop at that point.
And then, you just stay
there forever after.
But if you cross the other
threshold, you stay there
forever after.
And that makes it very
convenient because you can
look at what has happens out
at infinity as a way saying
what the value of a game was
at the time you stopped.
So you don't have to worry about
what was the value of
the game at the stopping
point.
You can keep on going forever.
And you can talk about what
the stopped process is.
And my guess--
or if you've read ahead
a little bit,
which I hope you have--
you will know that the main
theorem here is that if you
start out with a Martingale and
you stop it someplace, you
still have a Martingale.
In other words, if you add
stopping as one of your
options in gambling and it's a
fair game, if you can find a
fair game any place, and
you stop, then it's
still a fair game.
The stop process is
And that's as it should be
because if it's a fair game,
you should be able to stop.
So for example, a given gambling
strategy is Zn is the
net worth at time n.
You can modify that
to stop when Zn
reaches some given value.
So the stopped process remains
at that value forever.
And Zn follows the original
strategy.
Here's the main theorem here.
If j is a possibly defective
stopping rule for a Martingale
or a sub-Martingale and Zn
greater than or equal to 1,
then the stop process, Zn star,
is a Martingale if the
original processes is a
Martingale and it's a
sub-Martingale if the original
process is a Martingale.
And the proof is
the following.
You can almost say this
looks obvious.
If it looks obvious to you, you
should admire your intuition.
If it doesn't look obvious to
you, you should admire your
mathematical insight.
And either way, the kind of
intuition is that before
stopping occurs, Z sub n star
is equal to Z sub n.
And after you stop, Z sub
n star is constant.
So it satisfies a Martingale
condition because it's not
going up and it's
not going down.
But in fact, when you try to
think through the whole thing,
it's not quite enough.
It's the kind of thing where
after you look at it for a
while, you say, yes,
it has to be true.
But why?
And you can't explain
why it's true.
I'm going to go through
the proof here.
And mostly the reason is that
the proof I have in the notes,
I can't understand it anymore.
Well, I can sort of understand
it when I correct a
few errors in it.
But I think this proof gives
you a much better
idea why it's true.
And I think you can follow
it in real time.
Whereas that proof, I couldn't
follow it in real time, or
fairly extended time.
OK, so this stop process,
I can express it in the
following way.
And let me try to explain
why this is.
If your stopping rule tells you
that you stop at time m
for a particular sample
sequence, this indicator
function, i of sub j equals n,
this function here is 1 for
all sample sequences for which
you stop at time m.
And it's 0 for all
other sequences.
So the value of this stop
process at time n is going to
be the value at which it
stopped, which is Zm, when you
have this indicator function,
which is j equals m.
And if it hasn't stopped yet,
it's going to be Z sub n,
which is what it really is.
And it hasn't stopped.
So the stop process hasn't
yet stopped.
So Z sub n star is
equal to Z sub n.
OK, so as far as the magnitude
is concerned, the magnitude of
Z sub n is going to be less than
or equal to the sum of
those magnitudes.
And the sum of those magnitudes,
you can just
ignore the indicator functions
because they're either 0 or 1.
So we can upper bound
them by 1.
So Z sub n star is less than
or equal to the sum over m
less than n of Z sub
n plus Z sub n.
And this means that the expected
value of Z sub n star
has to be less than infinity
because what it is in this
bound here is a sum
of finite numbers.
When you take a finite sum--
this is a finite sum.
There are only n plus
1 terms in it.
When you take a finite sum of
finite numbers, you get
something finite.
So expected value
of Z sub n is--.
Excuse me.
I was a little bit
quick about that.
The expected value of Z sub n
star is now less than or equal
to the expected value of each
of the Z sub n's plus the
expected value of Z sub n.
Since the Z process is a
Martingale, you know that all
of those expected values
are finite.
And since all of those expected
values are finite,
the expected value of Z sub n
star is finite as we said.
OK, so let's try to trace out
what happens if we look at the
expected value of Z sub n star
conditional on the past
history up until
time n minus 1.
We'll rewrite Z sub n star in
terms of this expression here.
So it's the sum over m less than
n of the expected value
of the stopping point if the
stopping point was equal to m
plus the expected value of Z
sub n if the stopping point
was greater than n.
So we just want to analyze
all of those terms.
So we look at them.
There's nothing complicated
about it.
The expected value of this term
here, expected value of
Zm times i of j equals
m given Zn minus 1.
And now, we're going to be
child-like about it.
And we're going to assume a
particular sample sequence,
which is equal to little
z n minus 1.
What is this expected
value here?
It has to be Z sub n
if j is equal to m.
Why is that?
That's the argument I was just
going through before.
What's the expected value of a
random variable conditional on
the random variable, that same
random variable, having a
particular value?
The fact that you're given
a large number of these
quantities doesn't make
any difference.
The main thing that you're given
here is the value of Z
sub n being little z sub m,
which says this quantity is
equal to little z sub m
if j is equal to m.
That's equal to 0 if j is
unequal to m, which in fact is
just equal to Zm times the
indicator function of j.
OK, so you--
and the same thing happens
for the indicator
function of j equals n.
This should be j greater
than or equal to n.
This is Zn minus 1.
And we add these things up.
And what we get, finally,
is this sum here.
And now, you look at this last
term here, which is a
combination of here and here.
And this is just the indicator
function for j greater than or
equal to n minus 1.
And if you look back at the
definition of Z sub n star,
this is just Z star
of n minus 1.
I see a lot of blank faces.
But this is the kind
of thing you almost
have to look at twice.
So we'll let it go with that.
So this shows that the expected
value of Z sub n star
given the past of the original
process is equal to Z
star n minus 1.
That's not quite
what you want.
You want the expected value of
Zn star given Z star of n
minus 1 to be equal to
Z star n minus 1.
In other words, you want to be
able to replace this quantity
in here with Z star n minus 1.
And the question is,
how do you do that?
And that's what bothered me
about the proof in the notes
because it didn't even
talk about that.
So the argument is Z star n
minus 1 in the past is really
a function of the past of
the original process.
If I give you the sample
values of the original
process, you can tell me where
the process stops.
And you can say what the stop
process is both before and
after that point.
So the stop values
are a function of
the unstopped values.
So now what I can do is for
every sample point of the
original process leading to a
given sequence of the stop
process, we're going to have
expected value Zn star given
these values here as equal
to Z star n minus 1.
And since that's true for all
of the values for which this
leads to that, this
is true also.
So that proves it.
I'm doing this primarily because
I think you ought to
be tortured with at least one
proof in every lecture.
And the other thing is the proof
in the notes was not
quite sufficient.
So I wanted to add to it here.
So now, you have
a proof of it.
Consequences of the theorem,
this is for sub-Martingales,
the marginal expected values of
the stopped process lies in
between the expected value
of Z1 and the expected
value of Z sub n.
In other words, when you take
the stop process, it in some
sense is intermediate between
what happens at time 1 and
what happens for the original
process at time n.
It can't grow any faster than
the original process.
This is also almost intuitively
obvious.
And it's proven in
section 7.8.
So you can find it there.
It's quite a bit easier than the
proof I just went through.
The proof I just went through
was a fairly difficult and
fairly tricky proof.
Partly I went through that proof
because everything we do
from now on--
we're not going to do an
awful lot of things.
But the Martingale convergence
theorem, the strong law of
large numbers, and all of the
other results we're talking
about all depend critically
on that theorem that
we just went through.
In other words, it's a
really major theorem.
It's not trivial little thing.
OK, this one is fairly
major, too.
But it follows very easily
from the other one.
Do I want to talk about this,
this generating function
product of the Martingale?
No.
Let's let that go.
Let's not--
not that important.
So this is that, too.
No, I guess I better
go back to that.
We need it.
OK, let's look at the generating
function product
Martingale that we had
for a random walk.
So X sub n is a sequence of
IID random variables.
The partial sums form the
variables of a random walk.
Sn is a random walk
where Sn is a sum.
For any r such that gamma of r
exists, we then define Z sub n
to be a Martingale, this
Martingale here.
That's called a generating
function Martingale.
Zn is a Martingale.
The expected value of
Zn is equal to 1.
You can see immediately from
this that the expected value
of Zn is equal to 1.
You don't need any of the theory
we've gone through
because the expected value of
the e to the r Sn is what?
It's a moment generating
function to the n-th power.
That's just this term here.
So this has to be equal
to 1 for all n.
The fact that this is a
Martingale comes from that
example of product
form Martingale
that we went through.
So there's nothing very
sophisticated here.
OK, so if we assume that gamma
of r exists and we let Zn be
this Martingale, well, this is
just what we said before.
So you see it here.
Let j be the non-defective
stopping time that stops when
either alpha greater than
0 or beta less than 0.
Since this is a stopping time,
the expected value of e to the
Zn star is equal to 1 for all n
greater than or equal to 1.
And the limit as n goes to
infinity of Z sub n is then
going to be equal to
the process at the
time where you stopped.
After you stop, you
stay the same.
So you never move.
And the expected value
of Z sub j is just
this quantity here.
What does that look like?
That's the Wald identity
coming up again.
That's the Wald identity coming
up for a random walk
with two thresholds.
The nice thing about doing it
this way is you can see that
the proof applies to many
other situations.
You can have almost any stopping
rule you want.
And you still get the
Wald identity.
So it has a much more general
form than we had before.
This business here, the limit of
Z sub n star going to Z sub
j is a little fishy.
The proof in the
notes is fine.
This limit does in fact
equal this limit.
What's bizarre is that the
expected value of this limit
is not necessarily equal to the
expected value of Z sub j.
So make a note to yourselves
that if you ever want to use
Wald's identity in this more
general case, think carefully
about what's going on as
you go to the limit.
Because it can be a little
bit tricky there.
It's not always what
it looks like.
OK, so we're on to Mr.
Kolmogorov again.
Kolmogorov was the guy who did
so many things in the subject.
Most important, he said for a
firm foundation to start with,
he was the one that said you
really need a model.
And you really need
some axioms.
And then, he went on with all
these other neat things that
we've talked about from
time to time.
His sub-Martingale inequality
is a fairly simple result.
But this follows after that
stopping theorem that we've
just talked about.
And everything else
depends on this.
So there's a sort of chain that
runs through this whole
development.
And if you go further in
Martingales, you find that
this is just an absolutely major
theorem which comes up
all the time.
And it's wonderful because
it's so simple.
OK, so let's let Z sub n be a
non-negative sub-Martingale.
And then, for any positive
integer m and any number a
bigger than 0, the probability
that the maximum of the first
n terms of this Martingale is
greater than or equal to the
quantity a is the expected value
of Z sub n divided by a.
This looks like the
Markov inequality.
If instead of taking the maximum
from 1 to m we just
look at Z sub n, the probability
that Z sub n is
greater than or equal to a, then
we get less than or equal
to Z of m divided by a.
So what this is saying is it's
really strengthening that
Markov inequality and saying,
you don't have to restrict
yourself to Z sub m.
You can instead look at all
of the terms up until m.
And this bound here you get in
the Markov inequality really
covers the maximum of all of
those terms to start out with,
which says that for any m, you
can look at the maximum over
an enormous sum of terms
if you want to.
And it does this nice thing.
OK, I'm going to prove
this also.
But this proof is simple.
So you can follow it in
real time, I think.
So we want to start out with
letting j be the stopping
time, which is essentially the
smallest term where you've
crossed the threshold at a.
And if you haven't crossed a
threshold at a, then it's
equal to the last term.
So here's the specific
stopping rule that
we're going to use.
If Zn is greater than or equal
to a for any n, then j is the
smallest n for which Zn
is greater than a.
It's the first time at which
we've crossed that threshold.
If Zn is less than a for all n
up until m, then we make j
equal to n.
So we're insisting on stopping
at some point.
This is not a defective
stopping rule.
It's a real stopping rule
because you've set the limit
on how far you want to look.
OK, so the process has
to stop by time m.
The value of the process
at the time you stop--
remember this thing we've called
Z sub j, which is the
value at the stopping times.
Z sub j is greater than or
equal to a if you stopped
before time m.
And Z sub n is--
well, we're saying that Z sub j
is greater than or equal to
a if and only if Zn is greater
than or equal to a for some n
less than or equal to m.
If you haven't crossed a
threshold by time m, then Z
sub m is equal to Z sub n.
But it's not above a.
So the stopping time is this
largest possible value that
we've got until the process
stops by time n.
Zj greater than or equal to a if
and only if we've crossed a
threshold for some n less
than or equal to m.
So the probability that we've
crossed the threshold from 1
to n to n is equal to the
probability that Z sub j is
greater than or equal or a,
which is less than or equal to
the expected value of Z
sub j divided by a.
Since the process must be
stopped by time m, we have Z
sub j is equal to
Z sub m star.
And the stop process, f
time m and Z sub n, is
less than or equal--
expected value of the stop
process is less than or equal
to the expected value of
the original process.
Why is that?
That's that theorum we just
proved somewhere.
Yeah, this one here, OK?
That's submartingale
consequence.
OK.
So that completes the proof.
And it's 10:30 now.
So the Kolmogorove submartingale
inequality is
really a strengthening of
the Markov inequality.
So you get this extra soup
to nuts form of it.
Chebyshev inequality can be
strengthened in the same way.
That's called a Kolmogorove
inequality also.
Kolmogorove just got in here
before anybody else and he
took those axioms that
he made up--
and he was a smart guy--
and he developed this
whole school of
probability in Russia.
And along with that, since he
had these original results, he
just almost wiped up the field
before anybody else knew what
was going on.
Partly a consequence of the fact
that mathematicians in
most other parts of the world
didn't believe that there was
any good probability theory
going on in Russia.
So they weren't really conscious
of this until he
cleaned up the whole field.
So if you want to be famous
mathematician, you should move
away from the US and go to Upper
Turkestan or something.
And you then clean up the whole
field the same way that
Kolmogorove did.
OK.
So the strengthening of the
Kolmogorove inequality.
What the result says is let Zn
be a submartingale with the
expected value of Zn squared
less than infinity.
Then the probability that the
maximum of these terms, up to
n, is greater than or equal to
b, is less than or equal to
the expected value of Zm squared
divided by b squared.
You'll notice that that's almost
the same thing as the
submartingale inequality.
This one says the probability
that the maximum of Z sub i is
greater than or equal to i.
And this one says THE
probability that the maximum Z
n is greater than or equal to b
is less than or equal to the
expected value of Zn squared
over b squared.
If you can't prove this, go back
and look at the proof of
the Chebyshev inequality.
The proof of this given the
submartingale inequality is
exactly the same as the proof
of the Chebyshev inequality
given the Markov inequality.
You just go through the same
steps and it's fairly simple.
OK.
So that is a nice result.
What happens if you apply
this to a random walk?
If you apply it to a random
walk, what you do is replace
this is Z sub n with the sum of
random variables, and the
random walk, minus the mean
of those random variables.
We have seen that a zero-mean
random walk is a martingale.
So what we're going to do next
is to use that zero-mean
random walk of the martingale
and then what this says is the
probability that the maximum,
from 1, less
than or equal to n--
less than or equal to m,
of Sn minus nX bar.
That's Zn because we're
subtracting off the main.
The probability of that is
greater than or equal to, and
we just give b another name--
m times epsilon--
and it's less than or equal
to the expected
value of Z sub m squared.
What's the expected value of
this quantity squared?
It's n times sigma squared.
Because S sub m is just the sum
of m IID random variables,
which have variance
sigma squared.
So you take the expected value
of this quantity squared, and
this n times the variance of X.
So this then becomes sigma
squared times m divided by m
squared times epsilon squared,
and the m cancels out.
This gives you the Chebyshev
inequality with the extra
feature, but it deals with the
whole sum from 1 up to m.
Now, you look at this
and you say, gee.
Wouldn't it be absolutely
wonderful if instead of going
from 1 to m, this went
from m to infinity?
Because then you'd be saying the
maximum of these terms--
the maximum is less than
or equal to something.
And you'd have the strong law
of large numbers all sitting
there for you.
And life was not that good, but
almost as good, because we
can now do the strong law of
large numbers assuming only
IID random variables
with the variance.
So we're going to use that
expression that we just did--
we're going to plug it into what
we need for the strong
law of large numbers.
Again, I'm going to give you the
idea of the proof of that.
I wasn't going to do that, but
I looked at the proof in the
notes, and I had trouble
understanding that too.
You understand, I have
a problem here.
I write things two years ago,
I look at them now.
I have a bad memory, so I have
trouble understanding them.
So I recreate a new proof, which
looks obvious to me now
because I've done it right
now, and in two years, it
might look just as difficult.
So if you look at this half
proof here and you can't
understand it, let me know,
and I'll go back to the
drawing board and work
on something else.
OK.
So the theorem says let X sub i
be a sequence of IID random
variables with mean x bar and
standard deviation sigma less
than infinity.
So I'm trying to do the strong
law of large numbers before we
assume the fourth moment.
Here, I'm only assuming
a second moment.
If you work really hard, you
can do it with the first
absolute moment.
OK.
Let the S sub n be the sum of
n random variables, then for
any epsilon--
oh, I don't need an
epsilon there.
I don't know where that
epsilon came from.
Just cross that out.
It doesn't belong.
The probability that the limit,
as n goes to infinity,
of S n over n is
equal to X bar.
The probability of
that event--
event happens for a whole bunch
of sample sequences.
It doesn't happen for others.
And this says that the
probability of the class of
infinite length sequences
for which that
happens is equal to 1.
That's the statement of the
strong law of large numbers
that we had before.
It says that the probability
of the set of sequences for
which the sample average
approaches the main
probability of that set of
sequences is equal to 1.
OK.
So the idea of the proof
is going to be
the following thing.
And what I'm going to use is
this Chebyshev inequality
we've already done.
But since Chebyshev inequality,
in this new form--
namely the Kolmogorove
inequality only goes up to n,
what I'm going to do is
look at successively
larger values of n.
So I'm going to try to crawl
my way up on infinity by
taking first a short length,
then a longer length, then a
longer length, and a
the longer length.
So I'm going to take this
quantity here, which was the
quantity in the Kolmogorove
submartingale inequality.
I'm going to ask what's the
probability that the union of
all of these things, from m
equals sum k, which I'm going
to let go to infinity
later, what's the
probability of this union?
And the terms in the union,
instead of going from 1 to n
to n, I want to replace
n by 2 to the m.
The maximum of this.
The probability that this is
greater than or equal to 2 to
the m times epsilon--
that's the biggest term
times epsilon.
I want to see that this
is less than or
equal to this quantity.
Now, why is this less than
or equal to that?
AUDIENCE: Union bound.
PROFESSOR: What?
PROFESSOR: Union bound, yes.
That's all it is.
I've just applied the
union bound to this.
This is less than or equal to
the probability of this for m
equals k, plus the probability
of this for m equals k plus 1,
and so forth.
Each of these terms is sigma
squared over 2 to the m times
epsilon squared.
That's what we had on the
last page, I hope.
Yes.
Sigma squared over m times
epsilon squared.
Remember, we replaced m by 2 to
the m, so this has changed
in that way.
And now we can sum this.
And when we sum it, we just get
2 sigma squared over 2 to
the k times epsilon squared.
What are we doing here?
What's the whole of this?
The Kolmogorove submartingale
inequality, lets us, instead
of looking at just one value of
n, let's us look at a whole
bunch of values altogether
and maximize over them.
So what I'm going do is use the
Kolmogorove submartingale
inequality over one big bunch
of things and then over
another much bigger bunch of
things, then over another
much, much bigger
set of things.
And because I'm hopping over
these much larger sequences, I
can now sum this quantity here,
which I couldn't do if I
only had an m here.
If I replaced this 2 to the m by
m and I tried to sum this,
what would happen?
It's a harmonic series
and it diverges.
So what I've been able to do--
or, really, what Kolmogorove
was able to do--
was instead of summing over
all m, he was summing over
bunches of things and using
this maximum here.
So this probability is
less than or equal
to something finite.
If I now let k go to infinity,
this term goes to 0, which
says that the tail end of this
whole big thing goes to 0 as k
gets larger, for any
epsilon at all.
But now, this doesn't quite look
like what I want it to
look like, so what I'm going to
do is find something which
is smaller than this that looks
like what I would like
it to look like.
So I'm going to lower bound
this quantity here by this
quantity here.
I still have the same
union here.
Instead of finding the max over
1 to n to 2 to the n, I
will get a probability which is
smaller because I'll only
maximize over part
of those terms.
I'll only go from 2 to the m
minus 1, less than or equal to
n, less than or equal
to 2 to the n.
So I'm maximizing over a smaller
set of terms, which
makes the probability
of this smaller.
And then I'm replacing the 2
the m here by 2 times n,
because now this bound is
between 2 to the n minus 1 and
2 to the m.
So I can replace it that way.
And now, it's exactly
the sum that I want.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What does it mean to
maximize the [INAUDIBLE]?
Now n is [INAUDIBLE].
So it looks like you're
maximizing over inequalities.
Is it something like that?
PROFESSOR: Well, Yeah no.
I probably want to take this
quantity, subtract off--
no.
What I really have to do to make
this make any sense is
write it as the maximum over
the same set of things S n
over n minus x bar, greater than
or equal to 2 epsilon.
OK?
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Another thing--
you're more likely to be bigger
than a smaller quantity.
Your n is smaller than 2 to the
m, you're more likely to
be bigger than a smaller
quantity.
So you're not bounding
correctly, it would seem.
Oh, no.
You're doing 2 times m.
PROFESSOR: Well, there's
no problem here.
I think the question is here.
Can I reduce this maximum down
to a smaller sum and get a
smaller probability?
Oh, yes.
There's a smaller probability
that this smaller max will
exceed a limit than if this
will exceed a limit.
So I should do it
in two steps.
In fact, you pointed
it out here.
I should do it in three steps.
So the first step replaces this
maximum with this maximum.
Then the second step is going
to go through that step.
And the third one is going to
replace the m here with the n.
Anyway.
I think it's OK, with a
few minor twiddles.
And before the term is over, I
will get a new set of notes
out on the web, and you can
check them to see if you're
actually satisfied
with it, OK?
OK.
So finally, the martingale
convergence theorem.
I'm not even going to try to
prove this at all, but you
might have some imagination
for how this follows from
dealing with stop
processes, also.
What it says is Z sub n
is a martingale again.
We're going to assume that
there's something finite m, so
the expected value of Zn is
less than or equal to n.
So what I'm saying is the
expected value of Z sub n is
now bounded--
it's not finite, it's
more than finite--
it's bounded.
It can never exceed
this quantity.
I can have an expected value Z
sub n, which is equal to 2 to
the n, and that's fine
for every n.
But it's not bounded.
This quantity, I'm assuming
it's bounded.
And then, according to this
super theorem, there's a
random variable, Z. And
don't ask what Z is.
Z is usually a very complicated
random variable.
All this is doing is
saying it exists.
You don't know what it is.
Such that the limit, as n goes
to infinity, is Z sub n, is
equal to this random variable.
In other words, the limit of Z
sub n minus Z is equal to 0 as
n goes to infinity.
And the texts proves the theorem
with the additional
constraint that the expected
value of Z sub
n squared is bounded.
Either one of those bounds is a
very big constraint on these
martingales.
So the way you use these
theorems is you take an
original problem that you're
dealing with and you twist it
around, then you massage it and
you do all sorts of things
to it all in order to get
another martingale, which
satisfies this bound
in the constraint.
Then you apply this theorem, and
then you go back to where
you started.
So that's the sort of general
way of dealing with this.
And you see this theorem being
used in all sorts of strange
places where you would never
expect it to be used.
For those of you in the
communication field, about a
couple of years ago, there was
a very famous paper dealing
with something called polar
codes, which is
a new kind of coding--
very careful.
And they guy, in order to
prove that these codes
worked, used that.
I don't know how--
I haven't checked it out
yet-- but that was
crucial in his proofs.
So he had to turn these things
into martingales somehow and
then use that proof.
OK.
We talked about branching
processes, about the
remarkable things about them.
This theorem applies directly to
these branching processes.
A branching process,
you remember--
the number of elements or
organisms or whatever, at time
n is the number of offspring
of the set of elements at
time n minus 1.
Each element at each time has a
random number of offspring,
which is independent of time
that's independent of all the
other elements.
And it's a random variable Y.
And the expected value of X
sub n is going to be X sub n
minus 1 times the expected
value of Y, because X sub n
minus 1 is the number of
elements in the n minus
first generation.
Y bar is the expected
number of offspring
of each one of them.
So you look at it
and you say, ah.
That theorem doesn't work.
No good.
You walk away.
Then somebody else who is really
interested in branching
processes says, oh, this
process is growing as--
I mean it's growing by Y
bar every unit of time.
So I should be able to deal
with that somehow.
So I say, OK.
Let's look at the number
of elements in the n-th
generation and divide
it by Y to the n.
When you do this,
what happens?
The expected value of X n
divided by Y bar to the n is
going to be equal to X sub n
minus 1 over Y bar sub n minus
1 times
AUDIENCE: You need
to [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes.
That would help, wouldn't it.
Thank you.
Given X n minus 1 divided by
Y bar n times n minus 1.
And Xn minus 2 over
Y bar n minus 2.
And so if we're given these
things, we don't have to worry
about this quantity if we're
just given a number in each
generation.
If we're given a number in
generation n minus 1, the
expected value of X sub n over
Y n is just X n minus 1.
Expected value, we pick up
another value of Y divided by
Y bar to the n, which is
X n minus 1 over Y
bar the n minus 1.
OK.
So the theorem applies here
because that expected value is
just 1, then.
And this is a martingale.
So the theorem says
that this quantity
approaches a random variable.
And what does that mean?
Well, if you observe this
process for a long time, it
might die out.
If it dies out and it
stays died out-- it
never comes back again.
And if it doesn't die out, it's
going to start to grow.
And if it starts to grow,
it's going to start to
grow in this why.
After a very long time, if it's
growing, X sub n minus 1
is humongous, and the law of
large numbers says that the
next generation should have very
close to X sub n minus 1
times the Y bar elements
in it.
So it says that after you get
started, this thing wobbles
around trying to decide whether
it's going to go to
zero or decide to get large.
But if one starts to get large,
then it becomes very
stable from that time on.
And it's going to increase by Y
bar with each unit of time.
If it decides it's going to die
out, it goes to 0 and it
stays there.
So what the theorem is saying
is just what I just said--
namely X to the n over Y bar n
in fact either grows in this
very regular Y or it goes
to 0 and it stays there.
So this random variable is 0
with a probability that the
process dies out, and we
evaluated that before.
The other values of it are
very hard to evaluate.
The other values depend on how
long this thing takes.
If it's not going to go to 0,
how long does it take before
it really takes off?
And sometimes it takes a long
time before it really takes
off, sometimes it takes a short
time, and that's what
the random variable Z is.
But the random variable Z says
that after a very long time,
the value of this process is
X sub n is going to be
approximately Z times this
quantity here, which is
growing exponentially.
OK.
That gives us the martingale
convergence theorem.
Next time, I will try to review
at least the whole
course from Markov chains on.